Gisele Bundchen spotted out to dinner
with her martial arts teacher Joachim
Valente check out the model who's
vacationing in Costa Rica leaving the
restaurant with the instructor who she
trained with in Miami
during her night out giselle's also
joined by some friends and her kids
Benjamin and Vivian who she shares with
NFL star Tom Brady this outing comes
after newly single Gisele finalized her
divorce from the athlete in October I
feel like I'm so driven to succeed in
football and that's taken me away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife so fans are wondering could
things be taking a romantic turn between
Gisele and her martial arts instructor
well a source confirms to ET the two are
not dating quote Joachim and his brother
Jordan are Giselle and her son's martial
arts teachers adding that both brothers
are in Costa Rica while she spends time
with her two children meanwhile ETS
learned Tom and Giselle agreed to join
custody of their kids they're just the
biggest blessing Giselle released a
statement following the announcement of
their divorce reading in part quote the
decision to end a marriage is never easy
but we have Grown Apart Giselle
maintained that their children will be a
priority as they continue co-parenting
to give them the love care and attention
they greatly deserve she's really held
it down for our family and I'm just
super grateful that you know she really
committed so much of her time the last
you know 14 years to make sure
everything was so stable at home so I
could go live my dream at the time of
their separation the source told ET that
Gisele was devastated to end things with
Tom but she needed to put her and her
kids first you're a very public figure
and your personal life spills over
and
it's created I'm sure a number of
challenges for you this season I think
there's a lot of professionals in life
that go through things that they deal
with that work and they deal with at
home and obviously the good news is
things it's a very amicable situation
earlier this month Tom broke his silence
on the divorce on the Serious XM podcast
let's go I'm really focused on two
things and taking care of my family
and certainly my children and secondly
doing the best job I can to win football
games so that's what professionals do
you focus at work when it's time to work
and then when you come home you focus on
the priorities that are at home and Tom
shares this message for how he's
handling the challenges of his home and
work life we do the best we could do and
I have incredible parents that have
always taught me the right way to do
things you know I want to be a great
father to my children and I always try
to do things the right way as well and
to deal with things that in your life
that have challenges you want to deal
with the in the best possible way so I
want to always be able to hold my head
high on and off the field and I'm going
to try to continue to do that for as
long as I'm here
foreign